[Music]
you mix action and comedy a lot I think
we have a clip here from something
called rocket jump yeah this is one of
our youtube videos yeah yeah we show it
right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sure that military is gonna want to
talk to you these are fantastic
techniques
you guys have we're out of time but I
understand that you wanted me to do
something to help you out we're
finishing up the third season and we
realized we need that we need the Cameo
and we're wondering if you want to be in
the show the last season of vegan high
school yeah sure okay all right great
my approach okay you guys have like a is
there a green screen yeah they have
green screens ready to go all the time
yeah they heard that you guys are
perfect what does it I do well you'd be
a new thing to rerun a wine fridge I'm
the news anchor and my line is our top
story
vGHS barely survives their first playoff
match but dot dot dot a little more
excited big deal he's right I was
reading the cop good man he's 11 year
olds were yelling at me I've got two
billion views he says all right here we
go ready want me to be a character or
might just oh what am i doing oh sorry
we're gonna and you're really gonna use
this yes this is going right in the show
oh wow okay so I get paid welcome to the
web our top story vGHS barely survives
their first playoff match but they
killed it nailed it
[Applause]
more intensity yeah watch this our top
story
vGHS barely survives their first playoff
stunt but
[Applause]
[Music]
we've got him 77 years old